good how you living how you doing hey
happy July 4th week week I don't know
that's all I thought it was the main
conversation of everyone yeah is is this
it was last weekend July 4th as next one
is it okay when it's on a Wednesday I
think the best day for July 4th is
Thursday which will be next year yes cuz
then you get Thursday Friday Saturday
Sunday I got you the other one would be
a Tuesday Monday or a Tuesday B was
wrong Sunday Monday Tuesday right which
will be at the Tuesday last year didn't
we yeah weird I got you a present
oh really yeah this July 4th week thank
you
yes Adam has himself a soundboard
I have a lot of sounds and there were
some sounds I'm not gonna go crazy I
couldn't make this like a soundboard
game show but there's a few sounds I
thought we needed like Jim Irsay calling
Quinten well done my friend well done
thank you to Nick eg for putting this on
Nicky Jay guys coming up on Wednesday
for July 4th the actual we're going to
have a mailbag and there's a chance that
we'll be a part of that that guy skubick
Phil super excited about that but I mean
I got everything in here I even wanted
to put in the quote that's that's got to
be I think as we talk about Odell
Beckham your dad's awful imitation of
bid that the math his money also one of
my favorite movie scenes ever when Matt
Damon beats John Malkovich goes in then
and John Malkovich goes to be fine he
goes up it's okay I pay you with your
money from that last time I stick it in
you another one for contracts I put in
being interviewed while going into a
truck and saying when you as rich as me
we don't use chips straight cash on the
land I got a few good one and I got this
from your wife
yes I'm so glad she'll be so happy to
hear she made the soundboard
so amazing that she's official now this
was a weekend of non NFL sports but for
me it kept coming back to the NFL yeah
so the World Cup so great so awesome but
of course
Kilian in Bombay the 19 year old French
footballer as soon as he's out there and
makes a name for himself you're texting
me and then you're going yep that's what
an athlete looks like playing soccer
yeah a little bit again I'm not trying
to take shots at all soccer players I
understand there's a lot of phenomenal
athletes out there kind of like taking a
little bit I take shots because yes I
believe that there's a certain there's a
certain level of athlete that's not
involved in their sport and I look at a
guy like in Bop a who I don't even know
if I'm saying his name right well you
just went that 19 that 10 that kid where
number 10 is in Crimea he was doing
video game stuff and yes that would be
my point that's the type of athlete that
I would think you would see if Americans
put our best athletes forward you would
see Odell Beckham jr. is the world doing
video game things like he did to start
that game where he basically was like
I'm just gonna kick the ball and outrun
it go do it the whole way down the field
I actually had this discussion with one
of our world football people and I said
see what what Sims is trying to say is
that if you had a Tyree killer in Odell
Beckham on the outside and he was just
threatening all game to run as fast as
he can and go on a race yeah how would
that impact the defense of another team
and they're like I guess it would
threaten them I go look cuz it's a
football mindset to use different guys
to open up different exactly and open up
space have you had those kind of friends
Bob a if you know that I can just kick
it as hard and it's a race to the pylon
I don't think they have pylons to the
flag yeah let's get it yes and so that
happened we we started texting about
football players we did bring that world
and we got some tweets and then sue
Graham things I guess about people on
Twitter were like man that in Bop a run
it kind of made me think about Odell
yeah exactly and I kept to add elbow
down play it
Odell play without Bodell what or pay
down there there's money
but I'm told what to do I think like and
again no again bah pay I would be
shocked if he's faster than Odell
Beckham jr. an Irish Gil I'm just saying
that he's probably a better
long-distance shape we know that
certainly yes but that is the specialty
bath we first of all I'm rooting for
France I can tell you that right now
because of diplomacy and racial harm
racial harmony and diplomacy is what I
like about France and they're exciting
to watch they attack like it's about
them opening the field and scoring and I
didn't know who imbaba was I was
thinking any people did I was thinking
of the other kid who's the other guy hog
Pogba so I knew pagas name and the first
time I saw him Bop bags run down the
field
I went man this Pogba is real I've been
I've been hearing this name in Bob and
they were like in Bombay and I was like
what yeah so I also thought watching
world football Messi is a Antonio Brown
right and Ronaldo is Odell Beckham yeah
area there are certain things that Messi
can't do the attacking why's that
Ronaldo can yes physically right and
that's how we feel about Antonio Brown
and Beckham yes and what's funny is
people get so upset at us for not saying
Antonio Browns the greatest y receiver
in the game right but in his own right
he's incredibly incredible just like
Messi is yes do you agree with that I do
agree yes Odell is never another more
straight away explosion maybe not his
good side to side but still very quick
feet that can cut on a dime and I'll
defend Messi with this - nothing I'm
some expert but damn I mean he's a small
guy who's been playing for a long time
he doesn't have like just from me from
my naked eye he does not look as
explosive or as fast as I remember
watching four years ago of course not
you know he just doesn't exactly right
so I want to give a shout out to all the
people that missed on Odell Beckham
getting a contract including our man rod
Simba he gets June 27th Steve Stratford
Kevin when Austin Peck I mean we're at
like 400 guesses now someone though
wrote our man Chandler Franken Feld
wrote digs is better than Odell sarli
Chandler yep sorry you need to get off
the heroin
or hopefully not that Nick Rodriguez
says Aaron Rodgers the greatest
quarterback of all time
and then Joel acero also guessed
yesterday Adam Chris loved the pot and
may I say the merch is lit so again
you've guessed July 28th I have guessed
July 20th yeah coming in too early the
28th ain't gonna happen
LeBron I got a contract oh that was the
big news yeah I have a fan question here
from Kevin Vaughan - on IG with the NBA
Draft just passing I was wondering about
why there's a difference in timing in
the draft and free agency in the NBA in
the NFL can you speak to the pros and
cons of a league having its draft before
free agency like the NBA versus having
the draft after free agency versus the
NFL that's a good question I thought
about it and what it made me realize is
whatever is second gets more attention
so the draft is a second for the NFL and
thus it's your last chance to get that
wide receiver that your team desperately
needs right in the NBA yeah you could
take your draft but it's really always
gonna come down to free agency you know
I know the makeup of the league's
themselves you know you're getting seven
guys in an NFL Draft that could all be
valuable in the NBA you got 12 or 13
roster spots the one guy is bigger but
at the end the NFL Draft means more than
the NBA Draft it does it's a really good
topic of conversation that I don't say I
haven't thought a whole lot about my
first thing is I think I do think like
in the perfect world if you were an NFL
GM you'd probably rather have the draft
first and then free agency let me see
what I get the draft now I have this
market of players out there that I know
who they are they've been in the NFL and
I can fill in the holes the problem is
this I think with the NFL and why they
can't do it that way it's just more
people write the NBA draft okay it's 60
people drafted they know these people up
and down they're watching these people
since high school they knew that they
were an NBA player or caliber type
players right to where there's just so
much turnover in college football every
year there's no way like if we just
switch
like the NFL Draft and when free agency
starts in the start of March guys like
Bill Belichick would only have a month
to catch up you know after they've won
the Super Bowl I've been the Super Bowl
so I think that's why they have to stay
with it I think what our guy is saying
is probably correct the pros probably
outweigh the cons if they could switch
it around for the NFL and do the draft
first the draft first but you're just I
don't think you're capable of evaluating
that many players and formulating a game
plan to how you rank these players
whereas in the NFL you could have free
agency in March and April and you kind
of know those guys right and then while
you're doing that you're studying the
draft guys and going okay let me find it
you know the NFL is more about hidden
gems in the other sports yeah right so
it's about finding kam chancellor in the
fourth or fifth round damn you got a
Hall of Famer and the fourth of verdun
that [ __ ] doesn't happen in the NBA you
reach that point you get to the third
round and you got this quarterback just
going I don't know I I feel like they it
fits the league though that's
interesting the pro player personnel is
always gonna be more up to speed than
the draft at that point but I was
watching LeBron and I was refreshing cuz
I'm a Sixers fan I thought we had a
chance
I thought I mean I shocked I was shocked
then he went to the Lakers I really
thought it would be the Sixers then all
said and I thought he was gonna make it
was gonna be closed between Lakers and
Sixers but he would stay in the East and
do that it's funny because it made me
realize in the article I saw of Lee
Jenkins he made a lot talking about why
Magic Johnson meant so much sure and it
took me back to Peyton Manning's free
agency yeah and when I I forgot that
weekend was a crazy weekend of following
private jets of where Peyton's gonna go
and all the teams he's meeting right
it's not often in the NFL we get a
moment like that but what's old the deal
for him to Denver was John Elway yeah a
former great that went through and and
in his second life created the
Philadelphia's sold and the Broncos and
all that and I kind of think that's I
think LeBron Peyton went through a very
similar thing I think there's some truth
to that yes and you know I'm sure both
versal the Peyton was smart enough to
evaluate the Broncos and go with this
team doesn't need much they get a little
quarterback
by this D is special we can do something
we get a receiver or two and that's what
they did you know I guess where I look
at LeBron here yes I mean LeBron's more
magic than Michael right don't you agree
like I mean I know you weren't that's
what people have said there is I are
career that's what I've always felt like
I grew up exactly right just a more
athletic version of a Magic Johnson and
I guess where I look at it is I mean
unless they make another dramatic move
here yeah you think they're still gonna
get Kawhi I could see them getting Kawhi
I just I got to have a bunch of those
medium pieces they just rain I just
think they're how they been a
conversation on Saturday night between
magic or LeBron where hey LeBron might
be making this move because hey it's LA
and he it's a life move and all that
stuff too but I know he's not just going
oh I want to enjoy my life and not win
any more rings that doesn't matter so
that I can see something happen with
DeMarcus Cousins Kawhi JaVale McGee
tarik Evans we'll see guys will take
less to play yeah I'm surprised LeBron
doesn't take less to play yeah I got
some well I don't get if he wants rings
I don't know why he doesn't do it people
forget Michael Jordan was making two to
three million dollars a year the first
three NBA championships he made nothing
he basically let the team spend it on
everybody and did lebron take less when
he went to the heat well he took less
like but I'm talking like do Michael
Jordan less so nobody see this is where
all these things get lost in the
commentary Jordan well they just get
lost in context over the years Michael
came back for the second group of three
and he said MBA you're gonna have to pay
me and they basically change the rules
of the NBA so Michael could get thirty
million a year back in 96 yeah
people forget all those things so I was
shocked like embalm LeBron and you have
a billion dollar contract and rings are
the name of the other day I would have
signed with the Los Angeles Lakers for
five million dollars he said go get
Kawhi go get everybody else I make 80
million a year from Nike I'll be fine
would he have been seen as selfless or
ring jay-z but he may be but I don't
know it seems like the rings are the
only thing that matters let me bring
this back to football yep so I thought
no don't apologize LeBron it was the
it's the story of the frickin summer but
which NFL player yeah would be if if
everyone in the league was a free Asian
yeah who would be the guy Mia in the NFL
that would be the first
dominoe who would be the most coveted
free agent and i went through and i went
its quarterback right like it we're
gonna start there who do you think it
would be so pull up the team's I went
through and the first thing that I kind
of thought about was alright so maybe
it's Aaron Rodgers right that's who I
think Sims is goodness of course yes
that would be my number one thirty-four
exactly right it's a little it's a
little LeBron ish right but the
difference is is this is an NFL 30 yes
right I get it so the other names that I
started to think about yeah all right so
Russell Wilson's at that sweet spot of
29 agreed
Matt Stafford's at that sweet spot of
Shirdi but then I start looking at the
younger guys yeah and I go wood guys
wait for a deshaun Watson at 22 like
would he get more attention than a
Russell Wilson at 29 is Carson Wentz at
25 more valuable if we're if it's the
first domino that Aaron Rodgers at 34
then I'm going man Jimmy G at the ripe
old age at 26
Mariota at 24 yep and then do you wait
do you go for them a Holmes at 22 or the
true Biscay at 23 is it just the young
quarterbacks who do you think if
everybody was a free agent would be the
LeBron James of NFL free I do think the
quarterbacks are gonna be that guy as
much is it you know again old Tom Brady
well yeah I mean he'll be able to be
coveted I don't think he's gonna be in a
list of the guys you mentioned there I
mean the other position guys that we
could say or maybe up in that
conversation right yeah who are we gonna
put I'm gonna put Odell in that
conversation of his age right now okay
the cool max maybe at his age Aaron
Donald at his age there in that
stratosphere maybe even in Jalen Ramsey
if you wanted to win corner but I still
think at the end of the day if we're
gonna make the parallel to basketball
yeah it's gonna be the quarterback the
guy with the ball in his hands the most
and I hear you with the Aaron Rodgers
like okay yeah if you had to pick a guy
right now and you need to win right now
I'm still gonna go Aaron Rodgers but if
we're talking long term like you're
saying a franchise we're building a
franchise if Watson didn't have the
injury I would go Watts his his year or
so and grunt right he would he showed me
potentially shown me off the fee
structure he showed me everything to go
this guy's got it and he's got it all
and he can be a superstar
he made you go big all season alright so
Watson but he's injured he said then
where do you go I think I would go with
Russell Wilson at 29 Russell Wilson
being number 11 on the NFL players thing
is one of this it almost should just
qualify the list that's the dumbest
thing ever he was I think he was ranked
in 89 and madam we're gonna get to
Madden ratings a little bit lighter
that would be Roddick undervaluing of
Russell Wilson man I mean I don't know
what else to anybody is watching out
there I mean it's it was the greatest
one-man show in the sport last year it
was incredible like that Arizona
Thursday night game when he ran
backwards it's a Fitz and saying you
would think you think Russell Wilson if
we're starting a franchise and it's that
he'll be the number one guy over all the
young quarterbacks cuz I read this
weekend that said Russell Wilson's an
MVP somebody and what a defensive
lineman said it this weekend but yes
overall the quarterbacks I think age
leadership you know the professionalism
and then the ability to be good and any
offensive system he has that that's like
what I know we talked about that's where
I think like guys like Rogers Wentz you
know Russell Wilson separate themselves
because the system doesn't matter
because there's so physically gifted
they can just basically be like oh we're
calling that play for him seventh grade
still don't worry coach I'll make it
happen if we were actually drafting
where does Matt Stafford go in the NFL
circles he's gonna go a lot higher than
the public surface
yeah the public circles right I realized
this every offseason yeah I know
none of y'all watch you don't watch you
sit there and you count yards and then
that guy's good I mean these the Madden
rankings that the top 100 rankings in
which you got like Matt Ryan and these
guys over matters over and over Stafford
is insane it's an insane team matters I
mean I just watched that'll be the
greatest guess this is my coaching
standard let see even an Argentine
Argentina stinks I just follow soccer a
little I didn't know one freakin guy in
the team I mean no none so I mean Teague
ye know my Serrano no no say no I don't
know them that doesn't mean I don't know
yes I know so you looked out there and
went
[Music]
I got all this I like it Nikki G one
thing that was interesting about this is
to wrap up kind of LeBron in the NFL is
Miles Garrett tweeted out
LeBron if you don't take your throne
with you I'll take him take it miles
this is a few weeks after he called out
Kevin Durant for being a snake for going
to the wari right Myles Garrett is
getting a little cocky don't matter cuz
when they see him in person they ain't
gonna do [ __ ] to him but the thing about
Myles Garrett is everyone forgets that
he was hurt in the beginning of last
year yes and he still finished with
seven on second and I know a lot of
people are getting excited about the
Cleveland Browns but man like I'm just
miles Garrett could be one of those guys
we just talked about to doubt that like
you're invested craft him what he's a
no-brainer
is a no-brainer I watched two snaps last
year in the NFL and I said up he's gonna
be a superstar it's all you need to know
he's phenomenal he's strong
quick he's got good hips he's got
unbelievable power
yeah he's truly has a chance to be a
superstar he is the type of potential to
be the best pass rusher in football four
consecutive years I mean for four or
five years in a row yeah I really do
think he could be that type of guy but
sorry go ahead what was I was just
saying that like miles Garrett is is
becoming one of the more vocal young NFL
player something I love I do too because
I there a certain guy it's weird every
time he tweets it becomes a news story
and it's you know former first-round
pick and all that stuff but it's just
cool to watch develop yeah take the
crown from him in Cleveland it's cool
that's a good way to do it and I like
the way he called out Kevin Durant - so
are the Browns gonna be the hard knock
team yes Oh their win-loss totals gonna
be so high
oh my gonna get over hyped like the
Bucks were probably everybody it's the
it's the hard knock now I did go back
and there is no direct correlation
between being the hard knock team and
your your over win-loss thing right - hi
right but I feel like the public
perception always there gonna be people
are gonna talk about the Browns winning
the north all over them yeah that's
insane the Browns have potential to be a
different stinking team this year
there's no doubt about it yeah do I hear
some people that I you know again no
just go back to the receiver converse
there's a lot of potential all over the
team but I'm not gonna put that trio of
receivers in the top
in the NFL until they play a game and we
see actually then them do something out
there together it's but but all over the
roster oh line D line you know got a
corner now got all the things you need
to be a successful football because I
say so
that's because I say so alright I got a
picture for you
I cannot say heavy hitter in that music
plays heavy hitter would you be like in
your bed as a child listen to Funkmaster
Flex I say well even like it is always
on you know 97 1 and things like that
growing up in high school in college so
when I hear that right there it's heavy
hitter anytime I talk about tyrants
Smith you always laugh because you go
you saw him one time and it shocked you
right this shocks me I know Shaq and
Tyron Smith taking a picture together
and Tyron Smith looks like he's 511 and
out of shape and Shaq is just towering
over that he's up to Shaq's upper teeth
I mean I've never seen a human like Tyra
no no there's no human like Shaq though
ever is that just the difference between
NBA players NFL players yes well and
then Shaq looks bigger now because
Shaq's not worried about running down
the court now so he's probably 400
pounds where when he was playing he was
probably the same weight as Tyrone Smith
who was 7 inches shorter do you think
somebody like Tyron Smith whose entire
life is taller than everybody do you
think in that moment he feels normal
he probably did goes he probably for the
first time in his life feel small but I
promise you in his mind he's gone
I could whoop him still you think so I
can whooping I wasn't sure like really
huge people right it's got to be a
little bit of an annoying life do you
play man what's the weather exactly try
finding some [ __ ] clothes I was gonna
say I mean what do you think Tyrone I
mean they have to waste cash money on
clothes because department stores don't
make clothes that fit Shaquille O'Neal
and Tyrone Smith straight cash homey
that's me so they have to go and get
everything custom well I mean there's no
question there's no quite like Tyrone
Smith's you know ass we can't get our
arms around ya and then his waist we can
it's smaller than both of ours
that was the craziest thing right so
much waste right his waist his legs his
shoulders he's belt he's built like
[ __ ] Captain America or really
somebody
the other picture I want to show you is
a much-maligned player that a lot of
people disagree with Michael Thomas yeah
I sent you this photo people were
freaking out on the internet going holy
crap he's built like a linebacker he
definitely looks bigger check it out
I'll put on this Instagram what does
that picture mean to you does it mean
anything because a lot of people got
excited I know I don't know why there
was the excitement there there's a lot
of guys that look like that but their
shirt off in the NFL so you're not that
impressed no now he's a big thick strong
receiver there's not a lot of receivers
that look like him that so all those
Michael Thomas fans sorry bro well I
mean it's it's impressive
he's obviously in shape there's no doubt
about that like I said he's a bigger
receive the people they're gonna have
that type of body at receiver in the NFL
you know Julio the Josh Gordon's those
bigger type guys when they take their
shirt off they look like that too I
think one of my things though is this
year is really working on giving Michael
Thomas respect I guess because I think
in the playoff games he hit like another
gear he didn't know well he's he's a
would I look I don't look at Michael
Thomas ever on film and go oh wow I'm so
impressed by the explosiveness what I'm
impressed with him but his smarts route
running fearlessness reliability older
catches yes
so for playoff football when stuff gets
tight and physical and there's a little
more holding and the refs are chicken to
call it that's the kind of guy that's
gonna be able to go I don't care if you
are Richard Sherman I can't let you off
me or Xavier Road yeah I think that's
the thing about Michael Thomas is it's
hard I I'm not gonna put them in that in
that second tier sometimes with Mike
Evans and Keenan out it's like al Sean
Jeffery it's the same kind of thing
where you got the Robins there's gonna
be a place where you're gonna really be
awesome for that's the Superbowl and we
need you to catch contested passes yes
Michael Thomas is gonna be there in
those moments but he's not gonna catch
5-yard slants and ever go 70 yards for a
touchdown tired yeah speaking of an Y
receivers Antonio Brown the last week or
two Antonio Brown and Cam Newton have
been working out together a lot I've
watched a ton of their of an SL 1 video
they're working out with Jim Jones from
a Dipset Dipset to work out with Jim
Jones what said what what Mia yeah did
he hold the camera up and
go we got Championships again Jim Jones
in here we go why were you working out
Jim Jones Jim Jones used to work out the
place I work out injuries yeah maurices
he'd get after in their math let ik man
I never saw him do anything with his
legs I could tell you that much I mean
he was shoulders pressed bench in
pull-ups man he could compete with
anybody in that he was getting ready to
go out to the beach buddy yeah he was
the man he's a great dude he was having
a great time with them right so what
daddy down there in Florida somewhere so
I saw one video where they were working
on a beach together and they're doing
like a 35 minute run on the beach and
the Antonio Browns like back like a half
an hour before everybody else
Antonio Browns conditioning is
unparalleled off the tree it's
incredible yes I mean the fact that he
came back from that injury last year and
has that game against the jaguars like
his bone was coming apart from his
muscles impressive the other part though
was they were running a lot of routes
together and they were having like night
throwing sessions where cams just
bombing it too Antonio Brown and every
video cam newton kept being like I'm
taking notes I'm taking notes one how
does cams teammates feel about him
throwing with somebody else how does a
Antonio how does Ben feel about Antonio
Brown catching passes do they care
because I would see cams receivers maybe
being more upset but then again it's
also Antonio Brown exactly I don't think
anybody's gonna care I think there are
two big enough stars to where nobody's
gonna feel like they're playing sides I
bet you Kim's invited guys down there
too there's go if you want to come throw
let's do it I don't think there's gonna
be any issue there I could see maybe to
me just as the ex quarterback I could
see maybe a Big Ben being a little bit
like you know I don't want to say
threatened but a little in his mind like
damn okay where he's gonna go where he's
at least in his mind going damn I wonder
if he likes his footballs better than
mine I wonder if he's realizing his arm
is a lot stronger than mine like I would
be a little really insecure about that I
guess have you ever heard of top tier
quarterbacks throwing with top tier wide
receiver for the different teams yeah I
have a little bit yes just because at
times there's guys who live by each
other you know they're friends from
college whatever it may be they played a
college football together so it goes on
a little more than you would think
so you think Big Ben might be
self-conscious
like not to a bad level but at least go
through his head like he's arm strength
the big thing like 2/4 Mexico man I
wonder if he's more accurate than me
yeah all of it yeah all of it all of
those things are going play right oh man
is he throwing as he launching balls and
Antonio is going man his deep ball is
amazing it's better than Big Ben's like
those are the things that they're gonna
think of sure definitely and I'm sure
some of the Carolina receivers are gonna
think things like that too at the verse
I was worried that cameras gonna go to
Carolina can't be like manna I wish I
had a tenant ownio Brown hey listen the
mother he's got DJ more I'm telling you
that guy can be that kind of player at
least in my evaluation of what I saw
that dude from Maryland is legit I think
he could be a superstar and you know
let's not count out our guy that I'm
gonna still not count him out at least
Curtis Samuel the kid from Ohio State
you know he's got a lot of potential he
just never got healthy last year right
he really did so that's a little bit of
an issue but it's cool to see him again
man yes they got good levels Greg Olson
probably their most reliable Carolina
this one of those teams that's flown
under the radar the whole offseason yeah
well the whole Norv Turner story was
weird yeah it was felt like an old
retread know what it's not exciting nor
of and his whole family coming in to
coach the offense of the Panthers it's
the Turner's brought to you by Turner
all right so the big news of the weekend
though from the NFL front was kam
chancellor kind of retiring yeah he
really wasn't cleared medically to play
he had a big post and he said to walk
away from the game by choices one thing
to walk away from the game because the
risk of paralysis is another my final
test showed no healing first I want to
say so happy he got that contract in
because he's got more than 11 million
dollars of guarantee at five and six the
next two years that's awesome that's
five million dollars he only broke his
[ __ ] neck for the sport
let's not like cheap out now I don't
want to hear a deal being made for less
than what he was guaranteed don't do
that either cam you broke your [ __ ]
neck for the Seahawks one of your
special abilities that I am not good at
is remembering injuries to people like
you you said when kam chancellor first
got hurt you're like
this could be career-threatening and
nobody else was saying it what had you
been seeing this happening for a long
time I just I just know through history
with neck first of all neck can get you
blacklisted in the NFL like truly in the
black book throughout the league glad
you've seen this happen to somebody I've
just I know there's so many people just
through years of whether they had the
neck injuries in college and they had
potential to play in the NFL and every
team's just like uh I don't know it's a
neck you know it's it's contact sport so
if you see a player get a neck injury
your entire NFL's kind of circulatory
you're you're on them you're in the book
until you've been proven that you can
tackle a running back again head-on
Peyton Manning everybody was so afraid
of hissing exactly right I mean he's
scared - yeah kam is a different animal
altogether because of the defense the
position he plays and the way he plays
the game I mean it's a sad day a camp
chancellors and one of my favorite
players to play in football the last 20
or 30 years he is they couldn't have
been the Seattle Seahawks without kam
chancellor they would never have been
that special to defense because his
skill set of being a safety slash
linebacker 6:30 to 20 is rare it's just
rare to have that kind of guy to be able
to go oh he can carry Gronkowski up the
seam and then the next play he can take
on Zack Martin in the hole right and
stand them up and tackle Ezekiel Elliott
like that crap just that doesn't happen
and it's a very rare player and it was a
rare defense that needed the rare player
and it really all came together and I
guess what I would ask you is is he a
hall-of-famer that's why I was gonna ask
you
fifth round pick in 2010 four-time Pro
Bowler two times second-team all-pro won
a Super Bowl when they demolished the
Broncos I wrote down is he a
hall-of-famer not that long of a career
right super impactful I would also ask
was he ever the best player on his own
defense hmm it's very close you're right
I don't know I feel like there were some
years it was Richard Sherman yeah I'd
say it was some years it was Earl Thomas
I'd say some years it was Michael
Bennett - Bobby what'd I get you and
this is something that is a really hard
thing to figure out with a lot of the
these great defenses is they always end
up electing one guy to represent a lot
of the team and this was such it was a
system yeah and the system relied on
having certain parts I would ask you
before you get to Hall of Famer is Earl
Thomas kam chancellor
the most perfect prototype duo that
we've ever seen of strong safety free
safety I think so of all time I mean
again I'll go back to my story the first
time I ever watched them working for New
England Patriots and I had to go give my
Saturday like I don't know who we were
playing the next son the next day on
Sunday but on Saturday I had to give my
tombery I had to give him the report on
the team we were gonna play eight days
from now to Tom Brady so he could have
it so when the game was over Sunday
started I just look at this so I would
have so I remember walking into the
locker room and I'm gonna give it to me
because what they look like and I went I
would they are [ __ ] for real Tom and
he looked at me anymore
really I go I said if they're not the
best defense at football I don't know
who is and what year was this this is
2012 so this is like two years into kam
Chancellor's career Earl Thomas kinda
has found his place at Richard Stockton
Richard Sherman and camp chance or not
there's no Super Bowl year this is the
year they're gonna lose in the
championship game to the 49ers and the
four national losses the Raiders they're
gonna win the Super Bowl the next year
so this is 2012 and yeah you know of
course I knew everybody was talking in
the NFL Seahawks defense so good this
guy Richard Sherman who is he
I hadn't really studied them yet so and
this is my first week to study him first
of all I had a tremendously hard time
make all the jokes you want of breaking
down their defense because at this point
you've told this before cover 3 press
bell the responsibilities and the
shifting the NFL hadn't really seen now
it's everywhere it's everywhere then it
was still confused it was like like to
take it just to do a quick type first
play of the Super Bowl between the
Broncos and the Seattle Seahawks
Demaryius Thomas got killer yeah because
Peyton Manning thought it was man-to-man
and it was a pick play and he even he
got fooled people didn't even know what
they were doing and I told you I broke
down the game's
and during the week I'd have marked
tight end coach Jordans got see he'd
have to look over my work he was kind of
my boss on the day-to-day bye and I
brought him down like I was like do
George
I don't know what this coverage is man
I'm not sure I was like the receiver
goes this way Earl Thomas plays a man to
man but he goes this way in a zone the
very next snap I can't figure it out and
he goes all right we'll cut out all the
ones you got questions for it and we'll
talk about it after the days over and
the players gone so I bring it down 100
plays there was like 90 plays and now
and you know the first one was like
easiness I got you're an idiot it's
covered three years like are you kidding
me is this we're gonna talk about and I
was like wait you're gonna see like 50
more clips here and then like the next
play he was like okay damn what is this
coverage okay hold on a second and we
went through we had to call Josh in the
room and we had a figure out okay and
what was Daniel saying well he was he
was set us straight
oh no this is zone look at this he got
it all right I mean Josh was already
over just shot one time he's like yes
yes right so but he got us all over it
but yes so that was my first inkling of
Seattle that defense those two safeties
man special so you believe they are
truly the best safety combo in the
history of the NFL just trying to make
sure I don't make too crazy if it comes
with Ronnie Lott yeah it's nobody in
that Brian Dawkins had like Michael
Lewis but he's not I don't know no and
it really never had anybody ever had a
super special partner yeah I think this
is probably this is the conversation for
greatest duel ever and let's not forget
this isn't the conversation this defense
in their prime for one of the greatest
defenses ever sure I mean the greatest
season ever I mean just think about it
this 2012 the number four defense in
football always the number one scorer
always the number one 2013 the number
one defense in all categories I mean
scoring yards per game pass yards per
game rushing they were like number 10 or
11 but that that 2013 defense I mean
let's not forget that Broncos team was
the greatest offense in the history the
crap they lost 43 to 8 I remember that
there was hope in the NFL in I think it
was week one or week three of the next
season when Peyton Manning hit to deep
balls against Seattle in the fourth
quarter and showed a rink
that could beat the cover 3 press bail
it was this crossing route he hit him on
the sideline and then that's when people
found the cover 3 press bail beaters you
win the Superbowl everybody takes a week
to study what you did why did you win
the Superbowl what were you doing that
was different than what we did right ok
studied the RPO with the Eagles all off
all offseason you're gonna see a
different world with the rpoS this year
you're definitely well so it's it's a
little crazy hall-of-famer though I
think he's a Hall of Fame chances all
around yeah because I think he's in the
conversation for the best safety in
football for about five to six years in
a row he's in the conversation and this
is where I was getting back to I forgot
about this point I will say this my
years around the NFL whether I knew
people and the 49ers before Kyle
Shanahan when I would talk to them and
they were playing Seattle in their prime
or whether I knew Kyle and he was in
Atlanta and he was playing Seattle when
they were in there probably whatever it
was I can tell you more times than not
when people would break them down
there's two names that always came up
that I think people were like we know
Michael Bennett right yep that that was
always like damn he's so much better
than people realize and then almost
always would be they couldn't run that
defense without cam Chancellor I
remember when he sat out those two games
in the holdout and they got their ass
kicked and Bengals were like splittin he
might have come back from that game with
Tyler Eifert but the offense just didn't
look right for the first two weeks
because he was that middle linchpin that
did so many things he was a fourth
linebacker he was also a safety right
Richard Sherman is on the Niners Earl
Thomas is embroiled in some form of
contract holdout they never really had a
second corner yeah and now all Thomas
kam chancellor Richard Sherman Michael
Bennett Michael Bennett for me all
deserve to be in the Hall of Fame
conversation all thought all five
there's one of the all-time great
defenses in the history of the sport and
we've seen none of them were the Super
Bowl MVP I know and none of them were
the Super Bowl MVP that's right a guy
that's yeah Malia and Smith but yeah I
think they are in that conversation I do
Wow
I do how many of them 40 the 46 defense
Bears guys got
a lot of them right Richard dent Hampton
Michaels Singletary Singletary register
four or five immediate from the great
defensive injuries the 2002 Buccaneers
teams so Lynch is still trying to get in
and yes so Sapp and Brooks are in right
Ronde I think one is to right because
he's got like the 40/40 club or whatever
it is I don't think one she'll ever get
in I don't know if Simeon rice is gonna
get in close so it's tough the five guys
like I have a feeling Michael Bennett
might not get no Michael Bennett will be
the guy I would pick if you got he may
have screwed it'll be Michael Bennett
the other thing I was thinking too is
what the top three plays that I'll never
forget from kam chancellor one the hit
in the Super Bowl yeah which was in
cross the game you right then you were
like uh-oh oh yeah it was over Denver
Denver hasn't seen it sounds like
they're skiing that we watched together
you're right it was was the furqan we
got it right here at bleacher report my
second play that I remember from him was
the Monday night game against Detroit
where Calvin Johnson was going in for
the touchdown and he punched it out on
the goal line and then it bounced out
and he had that about should have been
but he punch on the goal line it was in
crisper fect timeliness yeah and the
second was the to leap over zuv the
Carolina Panthers in the playoff game
when he jumped over the center with ease
and I remember us looking at each other
and going he just changed the game of
football and you're not gonna be able to
do that next season because he just did
it so perfect right cam counselor was
incredible yeah this is I was wrong
script I realized this the other day
yeah if that was the first game that we
watched together at bleacher report I've
realized that we share a very special
moment in time yeah very special yeah I
snuck into your first game as an NFL
player oh the eels when ice me and my
dad my dad was doing refrigeration for
the Eagle Stadium right I put on a shirt
and I pretend that I was working and he
said that he went up to the gate and my
dad's like a hustler and he goes listen
we got we got a bunch of ice machines
down we gotta get in there and fix it we
get in we climb up rocky comes down the
opening a Lincoln Financial Field
I snuck into that game that was your
first game as a pro my first game man
nobody held the clipboard like I did
that day I snuck into the game who held
the clipboard I just thought that's
funny yes it's me we were in the same
place at the same time for my first on a
phone to having no idea that we might
meet at some point we were like ya know
100 yards from each other where the tube
as friends that anybody could have all
right so I got a fan question here and
by the way Wednesday's episode we have a
day is that when today when today's
episode July 4th we've already gotten
about two to three hundred questions
yeah so don't send any in we're gonna
record it on Monday cuz Ron could be
here on Wednesday but one that I wanted
to do today so good at Earth's sent in a
question about Nick Foles in the Bucs
any chance the Bucs are interested in
Nick Foles with this whole Jameis
Winston situation if so what can Holly
get out of them fly eagles fly Seamus
fires his Asian what do you think do you
think that the Bucs right now are gonna
wait this Sally mean they haven't caught
them so I think Jameis is still gonna be
there yeah but I don't know do you think
that's gonna do I don't know I I'm just
saying it would be hard for me as a GM
to have Jameis Winston as my quarterback
at this point I really would it hurts me
to even say that but I it's the truth it
just that's what it is
and I do think they're in a little
conundrum down there and yes Nick Foles
could be that type of guy I don't think
the Eagles are gonna trade Nick Foles
they can that's I wanna say this for all
Eagles fans because I've heard this a
lot a lot of people have come up to me
and said some people have even told me
the Eagles messed up by not trading Nick
Foles did you watch the season last year
yeah I know
did you see the fact that backup
quarterbacks matter in this league there
are not a lot of guys like Tom Brady who
seemingly don't get hurt and even he
does sometimes but you we are in the
Super Bowl window you just won one the
the availability that you look the
Seahawks are the perfect example
we talked about that team we thought
they were gonna be a dynasty and the
main reason is Russell Wilson's contract
we have three years or two years left of
carson wentz on this current deal i want
the backup I want all the pieces in
place I'm not trying to trade Nick Foles
for a second-round pick that who knows
what its gonna be next year the backup
quarterback is more important I don't
know how Carson Wentz is going to be if
he's not ready for the first three games
put Nick out there there are both
egoless Nick Foles is donating all of
his book proceeds to charity Carson
Wentz is giving free food across the
country they love each other they like
there's no quarterback controversy at
all it's the perfect situation is for
the most part a second-round pick it's
not necessary we're trying to win two
Super Bowls in the three-year span
that's the window after that Fletcher
Cox's contract gets too big Carson
Wentz's contract gets too big all those
offensive line Lane Johnson's contract
don't be turnover it's gonna fall apart
yeah so Eagles feet offense we're not
building for the future we're in the
future and now in the now yes
so do not trade Nick Foles but if a
first-round pick came in yeah
first-round pick and maybe something
else with it I know that's especially a
team like the Bucs really like you might
suck next year or they might suck right
and you also can play into their
desperation a little bit because I think
Jay Light and dirt cutter down there on
their last leg if this doesn't work out
this year they're both gonna be guns and
you could argue they could be the type
of team that could be desperate to do
that I would also say Nick Foles is 29
years old yes he's had one season where
he went 27 touchdowns two interceptions
another where he was the MVP of the
Super Bowl you could sell it to a fan
base he's our guy for the next five yes
but I don't know if he really is no
that's where I feel like in two if
you're the owners of the Buccaneers
where you have to step in and you have
to go he's not the guy we're not
leveraging the future for Nick Foles and
we don't even know if you two [ __ ]
people are gonna be here either so let's
just stick with what we did this
offseason you had faith in Ryan
Fitzpatrick and we're gonna ride with it
for now Dirk cutter has had one of the
most beleaguered head coaching stints
ever I do feel bad for
my doing nothing has gone in something
he's had very little support as far as a
football team offensive line defense to
help him out and he's had a quarterback
that's been a loose cannon yes and he
had to have hard knocks one exactly
right yeah so and he had Jon Gruden
breathing down as if they did trade for
Nick Foles
what do you think that means for the
Buccaneers and Jameis I think if it's
over I mean it's completely over like
they might just say don't even come back
you're a free agent next year do what
you got to do so would you have cut
Jameis Winston I've seen a lot of people
saying they would it's easy to say it
from a studio but if you were the GM and
this was your first pick in the draft
and it was your pick and you know you're
on your last leg and then there's all of
his actions off the field I think so you
would have I would have you know if it's
bell jar top that's a really tough call
but that's where you know you're a GM or
you're an owner or whatever and you're
making a ton of money and what's the
great the old saying like with great
power comes great responsibility and to
me this would be one to where you have
great power and the response you need to
do the responsible thing and this guy is
shown to have less than average
character as far as treating females
through the last six seven years of his
life problem is yeah is it that if you
cut them yeah it makes your selection of
him that much worse I know because you
knew what you were getting yourself into
and I I don't think they are gonna cut
them no they've obviously not no because
we know that GM's want to protect their
their record more than anything right
but it's a weird situation you I
daughter and yeah we all have women
close to us I'll be honest it's we were
both done with Jameis yeah we're done we
are I am totally done I was done with
the last season ya know this is the
final nail for me for sure it's just all
the information that came out through it
you know I mean the you even the you
know again the response to the uber
driver you know come on just say it say
it be responsible and man up for the
action like even like I love her
response her response was great I accept
this apology guy before the letter even
though it could use some work
yeah perfect response she's done
everything correct and to me she's
proven that it's not it wasn't just some
fame bruh I mean
to me this would be the case of going no
this is someone that's legitimately at a
complaint they handled it the right way
there's no inkling of attention
starvation or anything like yeah and
that's the true thing is is and I want
to say this women that are in this
situation I said this before I'm gonna
take their side pretty much a hundred
percent of the time something like the
ruben foster case though kind of was
like oh that's that was interesting well
yes but Jamis it's been consistent it's
multiple it's an issue let's go - whoa
big off see so which road do you like
more keanu that sound or Joey from
blossom that was Keanu that sounds like
it sounds like Quintin Nelson or that
one I don't know I think I like the Joey
Lawrence one okay so what I'll use both
so the really big was look at Joey
Lawrence no one will get a Keanu Reeves
Andy Reed was watching big rig old Chris
Sims girafft videos what because now he
compared mahomes to Favre Patrick
mahomes to Favre this was your big thing
during the NFL Draft was that Patrick
mahomes has a little bit of Favre
actually he went back and walked to me
and that was like what this the reason
that I love this whoa big offseason is
because it's not just Andy Reid's quote
it's uh someone inside the Chiefs
organization talking about the way that
Andy Reid talked about is even better
right whoa
Reid absolutely believed mahomes had
some Favre in his game we constantly
heard the comparisons especially his
ability to improvise and extend place he
raved about his gunslinger mentality and
big arm and how he could fit the ball in
tight windows Reid wasn't bothered by
all the crazy throws all of it reminded
him a far-right got a look with some of
that bad at first and that will be the
big thing this year wouldn't mahomes
that's he will have
throws without a B what I'll be watching
for yes it's just you know in this
drainage so on Alex bowler right he just
wants to go out and ball and make it
happen oh yeah coach you told me this
but right if it falls down don't worry
I'll scramble to my right and throw a
40-yard laser to the left don't worry no
problem I mean that's what kind of
talent he has and yes you go to
frustrations like Andy Reid went through
with Brett Favre early in his career you
go back and watch those NFL film clips
they're great when Mike Holmgren is
telling you know Brett Favre no more
rocket balls please and you know Brett's
ago I had somebody on my shirt you did
sure whatever he doesn't want to hear it
so he's gonna have to deal with some of
those things because it's what makes him
great I'm so excited
yeah you you you have to a degree and
he's in a throw I bet you four or five
interceptions this year where you and me
are gonna go what the hell was he
thinking that was so stupid
but he's awesome what but then he's
gonna throw like twenty other passes
where we're gonna go it's gonna be like
that and I'm yeah he's one of the most
exciting or guys I'm most excited to see
all right another thing that I love
about big offseason is when guys get
compared to other guys we've got one I'm
still shocked that the Browns left the
draft with Baker Mayfield and Ward early
and I will say this all the stories
about Ward sounds like a dick but
Bradley Cho was the guy that everyone
was excited about Oh Chris Harris came
out and said that Bradley chub looks
like a young Khalil Mack big he's around
280 around there he can move I see him
being all over the field
I think he'll start remember they have a
first round pick from a few years ago
that's still on the roster I think I'll
start he's been able to be that big of
an impact in OTAs I think I'll start
next year across from Vaughn for sure
for sure Shane ray is not starting over
Bradley Chubb different these are that's
yeah this is a different animal said
that the NFL quarterbacks were in
trouble in the NFC West because that is
us because AFC West because Mac and
Vaughn were in the same division
now it might be Vaughn and Mack on the
same team
Vaughn chub Bradley poncho yes what
happens if he is like a Khalil Mack on
the opposite side of a von Miller that's
when you can have a defense that might
be able to win the Super Bowl by itself
or with the very average offense still
be able to do that because they still
have pretty good secondary play they got
defense defensive tackles that are
pretty talented the linebackers are
solid to that defense is still good now
you have two guys like that where you
can just go man we don't have to rush
for we all I mean we can rush for all
game long it doesn't ever matter because
drop seven you still gotta add an extra
blocker to block Vaughn or do Bradley
Chubb because we can't leave our right
and left tackle man-to-man or Titan so
running backs have to sit in there
exactly we're gonna have to do little
things like that we're gonna have to
disrupt the timing of our pass game
because yes our tight ends gonna have to
chip the chip the defense and before he
runs his route and now the court
erections going where's the tight end
they're gonna go well we told them the
chip all week so that's where it gets
very little things that really change
the defenders of money bonds getting
paid well let's say in a few years chub
wants to get paid well - yeah is it okay
putting that much money into a position
of pass rusher I'm okay with that I am
and I don't think it's gonna be as much
when all said and done because we're
four years away from that mark yes right
and Von Miller do you kind of get like
the prime of Von Miller with Chubb on a
cheap contract I could move on from
Vaughn can move on for Vaughn or you
restructure with Vaughn to get a little
less and he might hit probably still be
good and then Chubb will be the star
that gets paid the Vaughn money and
Vaughn will have to go back to the Chubb
rookie contracts that is almost
something like that yes ma'am I know it
can be often very sleepy super sleepy
they are and really are part of the
reason why I have faith in them is we're
not betting on Trevor Simeon this year
who kind of deceived us a little bit hmm
Case Keenum yeah and that is our last
case keenum loves that Jake but wants
the ball I forgot yeah the Broncos
drafted Jake but Inlet not last year
after year before any tours ACL or
whatever it was
here's the problem with Jake but I can't
stop laughing because anytime someone
says something about them
I just think that they're making but
jeer last names but so case key name is
what his middle name is yeah I don't
know
he said Jake is a competitor he wants
the ball no matter what he'll come back
to the huddle and go hey you were open
on that play even if there's three guys
on him he's like yeah you could have
fitted in so the but says you could have
fitted in right I'm a child this though
I feel like the coaches are starting to
get in on the act
offensive coordinator bill Musgrave says
he's gonna be a terrific asset for us
yes that's a joke right asset but like
are they just gonna do this all year I
didn't like you know what the bike what
do you mean yeah the best thing about
Jake but is he just knows how to turn
the other cheek like ice are they gonna
do this all year I just when he squeezes
one out it's an incredible play there by
Jake terrific asset asset that's awesome
like I feel like with Jake but I would
just do this all year long yeah I love
what he he cuts the ride off and just
squats in the middle just sits on it I
like when the butt sits in the middle of
the field there's two T's to as I'm
sitting here looking at it's a real but
it is a real but I need to grow up no
you don't look you're good I think he
will be a real asset to two because he's
well I think what was being said there
by Bill Musgrave too is he's not gonna
he's not gonna like set records in the
pass game that's not what he is these
are good all-around tight at a session
you know what was he drafted in the
fourth round maybe after the ACL tear
and all that he's probably a third
rounder if he didn't have the AC ta CL
maybe second nothing he does extremely
great but does everything good ran yeah
Musgrave will be able to use a guy like
that for sure and as Nicky G says but is
a real tight end but it is a real tight
end it's too it's too many I can't
handle it alright so I talked earlier
about the rating systems and how it's
it's weird when I look at a people look
at your ratings and say you're crazy we
look at other people's ratings and say
they're crazy but I think one of our
favorite guys had a very good bone to
pick with the Madden ratings Akeem Hicks
the Madden accounts weeded out about
Tyreke he'll be like man we're still
trying to understand
about this speed and he came back and
said while you over there think and fix
my rating how did I go from an 86 to an
85 with a better season Hicks went to a
was a Pro Bowl alternate he should have
gone to the Pro Bowl he didn't make the
top 100 cut either
yes stupid Akeem Hicks is a top 10
defensive line in the NFL definitely yes
Garin Roger exactly right now he is a he
is in the conversation without question
for one of the five or six best interior
Diliman in football you want to know how
bad the madding ratings were but there
was only one guy on the Bears with a
higher rating than Akeem Hicks who was
it they righted an 88 let me just think
you're never gonna get it
it's a D lineman there's a defense nope
it is defense okay so did I give fuller
not Goldman not Floyd look it's your
fourth guess this is why the Madden
ratings don't make sense don't tell me
like Danny Trevathan hold on the safety
Eddie Jackson mmm this is incredible
this is how bad the madding ratings are
hold on a sec who the hell am I missing
here hello and I gotta pull up the
roster here in a sec Adrian Amos what 88
does that make any sense no he's not
even the best safety on their team I
don't get it so that's this is why it
upsets me ratings are very arbitrary
yeah I didn't play in the NFL
I didn't play college football I wasn't
a coach Maddon was very important for me
growing up man to understand who was
good when I would see a guy and then
he'd have potential and he'd get better
I would look at things like throwing
power I look at things like throwing
accuracy for a lot of casual fans mad
and ratings matter yeah and to have
Adrian Amos and 88 it makes me think
that his agent talks to EA Sports first
thing I thought of is it really 100
percent I said there's got to be a
relationship there because why would
Adrian a Mosby damn near 90
I I don't know why was he a most of 88
and Russell Wilson's in 89
what how is Adrian Amos in 88 and Kyle
Fuller's not I mean he's the best don't
get it Kyle Ford is in the conversation
hurry he's in the conversation for like
anywhere between that fourth and eighth
best corner in football he's in the Cabo
some people might have him 10 11
whatever but he's in that convo Adrian a
Moses even mentioned in the top thirty
two safeties in the NFL
no but Akeem Hicks to me he's a 95 but
to give him and to make him go down from
an 86 to an 85 when he has a better
season was there justification on the
tyree kill thing no they were just
saying that it was it was a clip of
Tyree kill and they went man he's so
fast we can't even blink it was just
there putting out content they weren't
actually saying anything another one
there's been some people including David
Johnson said that Chandler Jones should
actually be a 99 but he's rated in 87
okay we shouldn't be in 99 people are
saying that no one has more sacks in the
last three seasons than Chandler Jones
he led it in tackles for loss
quarterbacks hitting sacks where do you
put Chandler Jones he's the sixth
highest rated edge rusher in the NFL
according to Madden right where do you
actually have Chandler Jones in the NFL
he's he's about right I would say about
right there off the top of my head
that's where I wanted to put him first
of all I know that's one thing I don't
know what the full story there had
happened New England New England's got
to be looking at that one you know we
might have messed up on that one that
that Chandler Jones has whoop-ass since
he's been there he is all over the field
I will say this I don't think his sack
output is quite relevant to us as good
he is like I think he actually gets more
sacks in it then I want to say he's less
of a player than his sacks say okay he's
not the best pass rusher in football I
don't care if he got 17 and a half
definitely better though I mean
definitely Vaughn and Khalil right off
the bat for sure those guys are about
the Chargers with it you're something I
definitely I'm taking both of them over
him I mean I'm gonna take both over him
I think Ingram and him are very close
very John's his numbers are gonna
continue to be very good or they were
this will be a big year for me okay
because this is where my point was the
last two years yes it's been really
awesome
but that is a very creative defense that
they're going to more of announce to the
Carolina Panthers and he's got to be put
your hand on the ground and play for 3d
fans n they blitzed a lot its blitzberg
that's what they've been playing in
Arizona the last eight years it's
blitzberg defense so there's a lot of
creative ways he's ultra talented don't
get me wrong I'll counter Chandler Jones
I'm gonna take Myles Garrett yes
Yannick and gawk wäôre Chandler Jones
I'm gonna take you on a concoct way
that's C there you're gonna that we've
already put him putting me right so
we're putting him right there but he's
right knee merciless I'm taking him
taking Whitney Marcel I'm taking
Chandler's I am yes I know like okay
yeah I mean DeMarcus Lawrence or
Chandler Jones I'm gonna probably take
Chandler Jones still it's really close
Everson Griffin or Chandler Jones damn
it's a different guy it's a different
guy because ever since is more compact
and powerful VA Vernon or challenge that
there's a good there's that's a good one
too like Vernon's gonna give you more
run support but Jones is gonna get up to
the top you go with Jones just because
of their value yes
but it's close its close because Olivia
Vernon's one of those guys too that he
deserves the [ __ ] the play up stat I got
another guy we're definitely taking over
Taylor Jones cam Jordan definitely
taking over definitely see cams tough
just because he's a little bit like
Olivia Mack odn slashes slash ish but
yes so but there we go yet 99 come on
don't we don't have to like lie just cuz
he's on your team you're off your
favorite guy preacher Schrager said he
should have been a 99 no he's awesome
nobody should be 99 s in Madden and
except for people like Brady and their
prime or Rogers in their prime or there
were six guys that were 99 this year and
I think they were all pretty much
deserving I think it was like Roger as a
Milwaukee
Luke Kuechly was a 99 yeah Luke Kuechly
was ranked too high in the NFL players
list Luke Kuechly is one of those guys I
think a little bit like Matthew Clay
Matthews where he's gonna have like two
to three years of getting Pro Bowls and
99s on Madden yeah when he's he's
deteriorating he is he's really good
still amazing yes he's really good still
but yes I don't think Luke Kuechly is
the best middle linebacker in football I
also remember a time when Madden didn't
give out 99s I I was gonna say that to
me Bailey never was doing that to my in
my era I don't
remember anybody have Madden NFL 19 has
the most 99 rated players in a decade
Wow
yeah so it's six so it's Antonio Brown
Aaron Donald Gronk who's not a 99
anymore Kuechly von Miller and Aaron
Rodgers it's not bad
I still think runks in 99 you do I do
I think if you were rating wide
receivers receivers and included tight
ends we always talk about our big three
big that's very conversation yeah so you
have Antonio Brown Julio DeAndre Hopkins
Odell AJ Green though I would say those
are the top five and then there's some
other guys out there - where's Gronk
sliding man it sits up there an age like
injury scare me like I'll say Gronk
might be number one yeah you would take
Gronk over Odell who Leona Antone I will
say this I think I'd take prime Gronk
over any of them yes
Gronk isn't one of the greatest
mismatches in the history of the sport
and it's not just me it's anybody I've
ever talked to who never saw him or
played against them and they played
against them in person and they were
like damn we just didn't we didn't
realize how awesome he was until we got
on the field you know we just you know
we saw him on film we knew he was big
but then we got out there we were like
holy [ __ ] he's really big and maybe this
isn't like how many times I've heard
that damn conversation I can't tell you
is it close like those guys in their
prime and Gronk who is the battle
between the most yeah to me would be
Gronk
I mean it's Grand Coulee on Odell those
those are the three those are the three
that had they commanded different again
I don't want to slide in Tonio brown but
like we've said before i'm a big the
biggest thing at the end of the day that
will always give me my final say is how
teams treat these players on film and
like you talked about last week with the
punt coverage against motel Beckham jr.
with the Packard him I've never seen
that done in any game ever since I've
been alive and watched film yeah I've
never seen a wide receiver on third down
get punt coverage triple coverage kind
of game Calvin Johnson was the first
time I saw triple coverage you might
have got some of that - you're right I
can't remember specifically seeing I was
also home team was like just it was just
him right so yes but that's the kind of
things people think about Gronk - like
there's games were
safety line back sometimes they might go
D end and linebacker over the top of him
with his kneeled and they both Jam when
with the line of scrimmage on the pass
play before the DN goes in he goes I'm
gonna give him a good Jam so my
linebacker can get in a good spot and
jam him to the other thing I'm gonna
rush for you like where would you put
Grunk in terms of blocking of alt he's
in one of the greatest of all time
that's where it gets lost in translation
you would take Grunk if we were doing
just past catchers you would take Gronk
over Odell he's such a weapon because I
like I've always said he's like an extra
tackle on the football field and on the
outside he is a really good route runner
who's much faster than people think and
he is just a huge human being would you
take Travis Kelce over any of them no ok
no it's really that special I think
Gronk is the greatest Titan in the
history of football I mean I I know
Belichick like say yeah he might be so I
know I'm not crazy in the dark before
y'all here
he's Bavaro but just like the New Age
version who's been able to stay a little
healthier than Bavaro Bavaro really fell
apart in a hurry what do you think of
Gronk's like cat-like metal arm with
like all the braces and stuff yeah it's
like the JJ Watt thing where I always go
hey Jay what Barry Bonds at the end of
his career right it feels a little long
I know I know but the Russians seem to
have a problem worries I know it but
there's no medal in there so they're not
allowed to have that surprise I can't
believe you just took him over everybody
actually can't believe it either as I
was talking and thinking in my brain we
got our man Conor O'Neill he sent us a
report about Manziel in week two oh I
wasn't really that interested but he
sent us a report for week three ok Thank
You Connor everyone I have one we're
actually like underline what he said so
Conor O'Neill he's wet he went to
another Hamilton game and what do you
know
Halton two and one they up they beat
Winnipeg 3117 so he said this is from
our our embedded fan reporter Conor
Niall said that a Tim Horton's field it
was packed and looking around all you
could see was black and yellow number
two hamilton jerseys so Johnny Manziel
is selling out Jerry
jeez at Hamilton fans wanted Manziel to
take the field so badly they even
cheered when he took a squirt from a
Gatorade bottle so instead of watching
the game Connor tells us that fans saw
him take a squirt of a bottle and
started cheering nobody squirts that
water like you man man I'm gonna buy my
kid a Jersey cuz you can drink
Masoli though apparently he's got a
little Alex Smith with Patrick mahomes
playing out of his mind
31 for 41 for 369 a touchdown and
interception
playing like a man possessed right this
is what Conor O'Neill brings up though
he's still on the bench Manziel in week
2 the Toronto Argonauts quarterback
Ricky Ray suffered a serious injury and
because he's 38 he might not ever play
again we already know that Manziel
probably wants to go to the 6 to hang
out with this Drake and the new album
scorpion so the big talk right now in
the CFL is could Manziel get traded to
Toronto and be their starting
quarterback that's what they should do
the league should almost force it I mean
if I'm the Canadian Football League I'm
like I'm calling June Jones and like
really going like do you really think
there's a future as Masoli your guy if
he is like yes I know and I've read some
of the quotes from June Jones over last
week to where it didn't sound like he
was backing down from Masoli like myself
he's still the guy yeah so I want to
know if it's entirely if Masoli like in
practice is actually a lot better than
Manziel well I wouldn't be surprised if
he was well I you know like I told you I
told you some of those reports from then
you know what was that the was it the
AAA what the hell they fo yeah it was
not as for the other America it wasn't
very impressive from Menzel in those
practices so yes I would obviously you
the CFL you're forcing a trade I'm
definitely trying to yes see if it's
turning yes a little bit yeah I mean if
you you are I mean it they had Doug
Flutie wearing number two in Toronto
once now they got the new double he
wearing - do you think Hamilton I mean I
would be upset if I was a Hamilton fan
and I've never actually got to see
Johnny Manziel play yeah I know but
sorry it's the Canadian Football League
man
yeah so that that was Conor O'Neill with
his thanks our report thank you
my buddy you are the man appreciate you
all right so nfl.com it is ranking
season and I think this is where we're
gonna wrap up they did their coach
rankings Elliott Harris I think did it
okay he does his program power rankings
during the season I usually disagree
with them all the time I think it's hard
to agree with rankings is what I'm worth
it is number one coach in the NFL
Bill Belichick have you seen these
rankings yet no no do you want to see
them or do you want to give me your
number two why don't you give me who
youth who you and your mind Chris Sims
is the second best coach in the NFL gosh
damn you gosh damn you I think the
number two head coach and football as
you're putting me on this bullet here
I'm sorry that's okay I think the number
two coach and football I'm gonna go
am I missing anybody here I'm gonna go
with Sean Payton same as Elliott and
Elias I like you very much Sean Payton's
two and you say that not just as an
offensive mind
yes total head coach who else are you
putting in there who else are you
debating okay give me that Who Wants to
Be a Millionaire what other coaches are
in this next two rings yeah the next
range to me of course Pete Carroll has
to be in that conversation
he has number three yeah that would
probably be my number three pick really
yes it sounds like you these are guys
that run the organization run the
organization and you could say what you
want about Pete Carroll his teams are
always competing playing tough as hell
and I don't care who they are what they
are what it is they believe they can win
because he's brainwashed them to compete
and think they're special and that's
part of his genius yeah you give me your
top five and then I'm gonna pick certain
okay okay so you have Belichick Sean
Payton Pete Carroll yeah gosh okay I'm
just that's what all the coaches are
saying the Sims right now oh man I I
don't want to give like Shanahan and
McVeigh the love yeah but damn it might
be hard for me to do that
even though they're one year in okay so
first of all Mike Tomlin is going to be
in the next combo I don't give a damn
what he is number four okay that's agree
with that I think so so so far you're
agreeing with this list I think I am
agreeing with this list at this point
and
honestly the guy that comes to mind so
here at number five you get the same top
five al crack-up number five to me is
between I think Andy Reid and John
Harbaugh okay pick one it's one of those
two because I can tell with your
reaction I I think I'd go with John
Harbaugh it's not a ball that you'd so
you have the same top five Wow okay so
back promise you I never looked at I'll
check Sean Payton Pete Carroll Tomlin
horrible where are the gaps like is it
Belichick and then a huge gap - Sean
page I think it's Belichick and a gap
then is there another gap Sean Payton
Sean can carry a peak are are around the
same level to me and then there's a gap
to Mike Tom I think there's a little gap
there yes I do
okay so I'm gonna say so by the way the
rest of the top ten he had John Harbaugh
at five Mike McCarthy at six Amy Reed at
seven Doug Peterson at eight yeah Jon
Gruden at nine okay Mike Zimmer at ten
okay I'm not mad at those he had Sean
McVeigh at 13 yeah well yeah I'm Dan
Quinn Ron Rivera that's fine again you
know I'm friends with those guy I don't
think they should be put in that list
yet I and I mean that with all due
respect to Sean and Kyle they got it
they need another year to show they're
worth their I mean I know they got a lot
of potential but I don't think we can
put him in the top ten yet so the Mike
McCarthy one mmm right for six it's
really interesting because I know I rag
on him about his offense but you love
him as a head command he does everything
else right everything runs the team
handles the media play tough they have
good game plans may be situations match
up and they play the game the right way
even though his offense is crap he
handles end of Hafs and end of games
really really well over time they're
always super prepared I mean that heady
play it's not his fault
Russell Wilson threw a jump ball into
play and haha couldn't Dick's didn't go
up and get it they the the coaching was
perfect on that play yes the coaching
was perfect on the onside kick as well
right his guy just didn't catch the ball
so those are not
right now that's where I think sometimes
people go all while they messed up the
end of the game they blame it on the
coach and you go no actually the coach
was a hundred percent right like that's
honestly my big issue with Andy Reid is
just his clock management has I'm so bad
for so long right where do you think
they have Kyle Shannon well people hate
Kyle there's certain people that hate
Kyle I would say they're jealous of Kyle
I just want to say this yeah 32 is Hugh
Jackson yeah and then there's a long
list of all the new guys right Steve
Wilkes of Arizona like I like 22 23 yeah
that's a little McVeigh 13 originated
McVeigh verse 13 yes
and Kyle 22 that Conahan is 23 Todd
Bowles is 22 Adam GaSe is 21 Marvin
Lewis is 20
Sean McDermott's 19 Jay Gruen is 18
Anthony Lynn is 17 but yeah I thought
cut Kyle shant hands right in front of
all the new coaches cutter cutter tile
is just not a political figure yeah but
I don't think causes politics it just
because of that there are certain people
and like we've talked about this with
years leading up to Kyle becoming a head
coach how there was a people out in the
world who weren't always fond of common
statement under Kyle Shanahan on their
website yeah let's say was how much of
the end of the year was Jimmy Garoppolo
was consciousness that so basically what
he's saying there's I'm a little bit of
a Kyle Shanahan hater I don't know why
but oh yeah Jimmy G went in there I mean
I mean just turn Jalen Ramsay come out
and say they got schemed to death and it
wasn't Jimmy G they were competitive in
every game with with the 57th best
quarterback and for cover me in a spread
before Jimmy Garoppolo got there exactly
so it's it's it's again he just needed a
little bit more talent than position if
I was gonna be anything bad about my
friend Kyle yeah I think they screwed up
I started CJ Beathard and even drafted
him I I've said that yes but within that
yes they stayed competitive and no the
questions are not about Jimmy G ERCOT
the questions are about Jimmy G we know
Kyle's off
awesome it's top five offenses and top
ten offenses like every frickin year
he's been an offensive coordinator we
have to see Jimmy G Jimmy G just finally
gave him the few extra plays they needed
to get over the hump
those last few games my question with
Harvey I do not think they'd be a
playoff football team if they were on
the Rams and if he was a head coach of
the Rams and McVeigh was on the 49ers
mething Kyle and and and Shawn are so
close and what they are even right now I
don't care about the team talent level
those Minds they are very close so crazy
they work together yeah you but for me
it's wild like guys like John Harbaugh
yeah who everyone can agree is a top
five top seven NFL head coach if you're
betting out like Amy Reed and Mike
McCarthy and those guys but John's
underrated Jim's overrated I agree yeah
but with John Harbaugh even though
you're a top guy and your team let's say
doesn't make it to the playoffs
you still get fired yeah you know yeah
in and why not keep a guy that you know
you're likely not going to hire someone
better than him is it how do I have
never understood that man yeah I know
because everything runs its course - you
know you don't remember the personal
side of it - sometimes people just get
like man we need a change in the front
office this guy it's just getting old
the message nobody's buying it anymore
everybody hates him now whatever it is I
mean Pete Carril got fired Bill
Belichick got fired so it's going to
happen Jimmy Johnson got his ass fired
yeah you know so it's just it's I think
more the personal side that sometimes
they look at like we just need a new
shake-up in the organization but what do
we know about John Harbaugh we know his
teams are gonna be tough physical both
sides of the thing innovative it right
like innovative ways like that that's
why I would put Harbaugh over McCarthy
and read is McCarthy and Reid both run
really good ship yeah but Harbaugh was
gonna come out there with some new
wrinkles and also I mean what he's done
with special teams is that's Rand he's
like the one team that's willing to pick
a fight with the Patriots and can win I
think that's where you give him the edge
he they're fearless about where they go
and play oh you want us to go to New
England
we'll go knock you will go knock heads
with you let's do it oh you wanna see
you know whatever they're they're ready
to play ball what do you think about
Gruden at nine yeah it's probably a
little bit on like Pass laurels and Doug
Peterson at eight yeah I think that's
about
I gotta see it I don't still weird but I
know I think Doug is this proved himself
to be in that top 10 conversation after
this year John is a phenomenal mind yeah
I don't know if I could have put him at
number nine right off the bat here but
yeah he'd probably be around that
conversation I'm looking to your list
yeah take it yeah just to look at it
like yeah it'd be hard for me to put a
Mike Zimmer or a Dan Quinn or Ron Rivera
or Sean McVeigh in front of Jon Gruden
yes it would be so I think that's about
right
I think John could have been anywhere
from six to ten I do hey listen he's
been there he's done it he's led a lot
of football teams to some great things
he understands the sport at its total
and yeah I do think he's in that combo
awesome guys you are the [ __ ] as always
I hope that your summer is going great
and I hope that you are having a big
offseason yourselves I'm gonna chill out
on the sounds guys we're gonna have a
special mailbag episode on July 4th
again we've had hundreds of questions
you can get the big [ __ ] on there
we're and we're gonna get big Phil to
answer some questions on the podcast I'm
super excited about that hit us up on
social as always at Sims and left go
head to iTunes leave us a review I think
we're at a meet if we hit a thousand
five-star reviews I'm gonna be very
excited so I have to check that but
Fenric will be doing we know thousand
five stars review bleacher report has to
pay me a million dollars not really that
is for Sims
peace out homey centric would say good
evening in the lef koe man says holla
holla fourth of July have a great fourth
of July guys if you want to care about
the NFL you better be listen to Sims of
love Co the players podcast will haunt
you ladies